[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview notre
invité est le ministre des affaires
étrangères du front polisario monsieur
mohamed salem ould salek bonjour
monsieur ministre et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
bonjour c'est le ministre avait
entrouvert de la république sharon
bowles alors on va commencer à monsieur
le ministre parle affaires à brahim
magali le leader indépendantiste du
polisario qui a été transféré le 21
avril dernier sous une fausse identité
en espagne pour des soins à la suite de
complications alliés aux colis de 19
cette affaire elle est à l'origine d'une
crise diplomatique entre madrid et rabat
est ce que le front polisario la
république sahraouie en tirent un
bénéfice de clarification tout d'abord
brahim ghali président de la république
sahraouie secrétaires généraux polizario
n'est pas entré l'espagne avec une
fausse identité il a un passeport
diplomatique africain de l'union
africaine un passeport diplomatique de
la république sahraouie et un autre de
l'algérie il est entré en territoire
espagnol
avec le passeport diplomatique algérien
ça c'est pour dire que toute la
propagande autour de faim de d'entités
falsifiés c'est tout à fait un montage
que l'on connaît bien
d'où il vient c'est du maroc des
services marocains qui ont voulu dire
comme si le président sahraoui se cacher
seul regret c'est chaud je l' ai déjà
dit à plusieurs reprises il est rentré
bel et bien avec un passeport
diplomatique algérien 2 la crise entre
le maroc et l'espagne et qu'il crise
créée par le maroc qui voulait que
l'espagne et l'union européenne suive
trappe
reconnaissant la souveraineté d'une
manière générale de la présence illégale
du maroc dans notre pays
depuis déjà plusieurs mois avant
l'entrée de notre président pour des
soins en espagne il ya une crise entre
l'espagne europe parce que le maroc 1
il a annulé la rencontre officielle est
à tiques houleux au plus haut niveau la
réunion mix entre les deux pays et 2
il a déjà envahi les îles canaries par
de l'immigration clandestine dont le
maroc soutient prétexte sur le la fausse
identité présumé de brahim ghali
lorsqu'il est arrivé en territoire
espagnol quelle est la position de
madrid à la position de madrid que le
présent sahraoui et secrétaire général
du front polisario est venu pour des
soins il s'agit d'un disque à sion où
les espagnols eux répondu à notre
demande et c'est pour des raisons tout à
fait humanitaire et ça n'a rien à voir
avec la question du sahara occidental
c'est un rien à voir avec le conflit du
sahara occidental scène rien à voir avec
la position de l'espagne sur cette
question
mais le maroc soutient prétexte voilà il
a utilisé ce prétexte et on a vu que le
maroc et est passé très loin est allé
très loin il a passé toutes les lignes
rouges on envoyait son le territoire
monsieur me dise comment va-t-il brahim
ghali d'une part qui assure son intérim
en son absence
et quand doit-il reprendre ses activités
à la tête de la république sahraouie de
votre mouvement le front polisario
il va sur le plan de la santé il va elle
va bien il est là il est les faits bien
c'est sa convalescence et son intérim
est assuré par le premier ministre vous
savez nous avons une direction
collégiale front polisario à nu un
secrétariat national dans les
prérogatives sont très connus et il y a
un gouvernement qui a qui assure
l'intérim gouvernement un exécutif et
nous avons aussi âprement donc les
institutions de l'état
fonctionne et les associations du
quartier et du front polisario
fonctionne vous savez que les
conséquences de cette crise diplomatique
et bien c'est une amplification de la
crise migratoire avec l'afflux de
migrants dans les enclaves espagnoles
quel regard vous portez sur cette crise
migratoire est est ce que vous le pro
polisario la république sahraouie vous
prenez votre part de responsabilité dans
le drame humain que l'on a pu voir et
qu'elle se déroule en ce moment
d'ailleurs le drame et main levée le
peuple château et depuis 1975 ce pion
soutenu le maroc dans son entreprise
coloniale et d'agression contre le
peuple sahraoui
ceux qui ont bloqué avec le maroc le
processus de paix au sahara occidental
asim aujourd'hui malheureusement la
responsabilité le maroc a utilisé chaque
fois à l'immigration clandestine
voir la drogue le maroc selon les
nations unies c'est pas moi qui le dit
et le premier fournisseur de cannabis au
niveau européen 80 % de cette production
mondiale vient du maroc et aussi tous
ceux qui ont assisté ou participé à des
actes terroristes notamment en espagne
en belgique et en france c'est des
marocains il faut que le maroc cesse de
violer les frontières de ses voisins il
faut que le maroc respecte ses propres
engagements nous avons signé un accord
mais monsieur le ministre vous nier
toute responsabilité même indirecte dans
ce que l'on observe aujourd'hui cette
crise migratoire ce drame humain nous
nous sommes madame nous sommes victimes
avant l'europe de sept de ses marche
verte que le maroc appelle verte mais
qui sont des marchés qui viole tous les
principes du droit international droite
nationalitaire les marocains déjà en
marche et pour cacher l'agression contre
notre pays aux marchés avec des marées
humaines contre notre pays ils le font
d'une manière systématique
contre l'europe et c'est vrai que ce
chantage continue d maroc l'on voit
aujourd'hui que les gens commencent à se
sensibiliser le connaître la réaction du
parlement européen c'est parce que le
maroc à continuer à envahir le
territoire européen par des immigrés
aussi bien marocains que ci-dessus
subsahariens juste une chose très
importante les frontières aujourd'hui du
maroc sont pratiquement fermé avec
l'algérie et avec eux la république
sahraouie et puis une partie occupée par
les troupes marocaines il ya un mur qui
ça par litre des zones sous équipées et
les ont libérés il y as ils sont
infranchissables
les subsahariens qui arrive à certains
médias et qui passe du maroc vers les
îles canaries sont promenés par
l'aviation marocain par herrmann il y a
des les capitales de l'afrique de
l'ouest il ya des déconnexions
pratiquement deux à trois fois par jour
qu'ils n'emmènent que l'immigration que
l'on dessine le maroc et tu dis ça
malheureusement ce n'est pas de la
propagande
il faut demander à aux organisations
européennes de quoi il s'agit alors pour
terminer avec la sphère brahim ghali
il fait l'objet de graves accusations
torture génocide et l'a d'ailleurs est
interrogé depuis l'hôpital par
visioconférence en espagne c'était le
1er juin d'interroger donc par la
justice espagnole qui pour l'instant a
décidé de ne pas donner de suite mais
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement ad décidant par
votre mouvement a calé à la ligne de
conduite du polisario à leur encontre
setc des accusations politiques qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les les
allégations portées devant la justice
espagnole
brahim ghali et le présent saadaoui la
bienne affronte et devant la justice
espagnole
il n'y a aucune preuve de ce que dit le
marrant mais je vous dis une autre chose
qui des deux le royaume du maroc ou la
république se refuse aujourd'hui que la
minurso la mission des nations unies qui
se trouve au sahara occidental détient
le pouvoir d' observer la surveillance
des droits de l'homme
c'est marrant
le cuse selon tous les rapports du
quinté rejoint des nations unies les
nations unies demandent une institution
un organisme indépendant pour surveiller
les droits de l' on va y revenir mais
simplement qu'elle sous les accusations
sur les accusations de torture et de
génocide
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
parce que ça pose quand même le problème
du sort des dissidents de votre
mouvement quelle est la ligne de
conduite je répète ma question du front
polisario à la rencontre mais notre
réponse est que cette question est une
question qui pose la question des droits
de l'homme n'est ce pas et les libertés
fondamentales qui refusent les
campements de réfugiés sahraouis libérés
sont ouverts nous n'avons jamais expulsé
ni les organisations des droits de
l'homme ni la presse alors que le maroc
les ont occupés aujourd'hui sont fermés
si vous allez vous même et les
organisations humanitaires le maroc
n'accepte pas que vous venez à laâyoune
dakhla
alors les accusations soit disant de
deux opposants in china nous acceptons
de recevoir tous ceux qui veulent
enquêter sur cette question et savoir
quelle est la vérité les accusations
portées devant les espagnols c'est les
services marocains qui ont manipulé des
personnes qui qu'il faut qu'ils opèrent
à la place des services marocains c'est
tout donc vous niez dire les problèmes
reliés aux dissidents du front polisario
il ya les dissidents du front polisario
c'est une séquence logo que l'on utilise
justement pour dénigrer le flambeau les
avions le clan pour les années par par
tous les sahraouis qui acceptent de
coopérer ou de travailler pour
l'indépendance de leur pays et il n'y a
aucune exclusion de deux personnes sauf
celui qui veut exclure humains y compris
les appels
y compris les sahraouis qui ont décidé
de s'installer au maroc parce qu'il y en
a aussi mais bien sûr mais mais mais
pour ce cas pourquoi le front polisario
accepté justement le le rafale honda
c'est parce que nous acceptons le
verdict du peuple et qui bloque le
fonctionnement
alors justement on en vient au bras de
fer avec le maroc sur le sahara
occidental ça fait 40 ans qu'il dure ce
bras de fer
d'abord où on est le cessez le feu qui a
été rompues en novembre 2020 par la
république sahraouie en réaction à une
opération militaire marocaine dans
l'extrême sud du territoire qui visait à
rétablir le trafic routier coupé par vos
militants indépendantistes
d'abord le trafic routier
il n'y a pas de trafic routier parce que
le maroc a ouvert une brèche dans un mur
qui faisait qui constitue là la ligne de
séparation
depuis 1991 les trucs sahraouis ne
pouvait ne devait pas s'approcher à cinq
kilomètres de ce mur ap les emplois et
les troupes marocaines ne doit pas
dépasser le mur
le maroc a ouvert une brèche les nations
unies déjà on tape le maroc a fermé la
pression 2001
le maroc a refusé il a continué à
refuser et quand le les sahraouis ont
demandé la fermeture de cette brèche
parce que justement à travers cette
brèche il ya les richesses allaoui qui
sont pillées et le maroc l'utilisent
pour le transport de ses richesses des
manifestants pacifiques ont demandé que
cet arrêt sera fermée le maroc les a
attaqués et le maroc a violé ainsi il a
dépassé
non seulement le mur de séparation
appelé mur de défense marc carnicé le
mur de la honte
appelé par les sahraouis qui est le un
mur le mur le plus long tri fait dominer
de barbelés et qui fait des dégâts parmi
la population civile
le maroc a violé le cessez-le-feu mais
le problème est que le cessez le feu
n'est qu'une composante du plan de
règlement
[Musique]
retour dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec les ministres des affaires
étrangères du front polisario de la
république sahraouie
monsieur mohamed salem ould salek à
monsieur le ministre on évoquait
justement la rupture du cessez le feu
c'était à l'automne dernier est-ce que
désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée et jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à
aller est ce que vous êtes prêts à
franchir une ligne rouge les lignes
rouges sont déjà franchi qu'on a guère a
commencé le 13 novembre après cette
agression des maroc après que le maroc a
annexé encore et partie de notre
territoire
les nations unies n'ont pas plu le bloc
n ont pas pu l'arrêter mais le problème
ici est que le cessez le feu n'est
qu'une petite un petit élément du plan
dit plan du plan de paix que nous avons
signé en 1995 ce plan de paix est basé
sur l'acceptation et l'engagement des
deux parties
le royaume du maroc et le front
polisario après 16 années de guerre nous
avons accepté un plan de paix qui
consiste à l'organisation d'un
référendum interne à sion pour laisser
les sahraouis le choix de choisir le
futur de choisir entre l'indépendance et
l'intégration maroc le maroc a refusé
d'honorer son cas son engagement et le
problème est que il y a une complicité
au sein de ray nations unies mais au
sein du conseil de sécurité
ce n'est pas seulement le maroc et blanc
il y à un pays européen qui a bloqué le
référendum jusqu'à maintenant
et voilà le maroc ne veut aujourd'hui
que l'on que l'on lui connaît ce que
l'on
le le connaissent le la souveraineté
tout à fait sûr notre pays ce qui est
absolument inacceptable
impossible on va bien sûr évoqué le
bilan de l'onu puisque ce cessez-le-feu
il a été senior en dise en septembre
1991 sous l'égide de l'onu qui prévoyait
vous l'avais dit dans le cadre d'un plan
de paix à un référendum
d'autodétermination dans les six mois
qui ont suivi mais le statut du
territoire qui pose toujours problème
entre l'autonomie sous souveraineté
marocaine et l'indépendance que vous
revendiquez au sahara occidental est ce
qui est un compromis possible en le
front pour l'usl ne revendique pas un
nouveau mandat et l'autonomie est pas
l'accord entre nos éléments
il est il faut une fois il faut placer
les choses telles qu'elles sont vous
dites la vérité la vérité que le conseil
de sécurité est garant du plan que nous
avons signé le plan de paix dit qu'il
est un plan pratique est un compromis
entre l'intégration au maroc que veut le
le maroc et l'indépendance qui était
l'objectif que nous avons déclenché la
lutte contre les espagnols en 73 nous
avons demandé comme tous les mouvements
de libération quand les peuples à qui on
reconnaît le droit d'intervention au
niveau des organisations internationales
nous avons demandé à la réponse mais
nous avons accepté le référendum
justement pour donner aux sahraouis la
possibilité d'exercer leur droit reconnu
par la communauté internationale
le stati et déterminé parce que si on
dit que le statut n'est pas déterminé de
territoire le statut est un territoire
qui au niveau de l'union africaine
c'est un état qui recollaient qui est
reconnu par plus de 80 pays dont le nom
est au niveau des nations unies on le
traite toujours qu'on était étant un
territoire non autonome à savoir que ce
n'est pas une partie du territoire
marocain
la cour internationale de justice de
9,75 déjà averti et toutes les
organisations internationales ne
reconnaissent pas la souveraineté du
maroc 2 2
c'est le salon et sur le bilan de l'onu
monsieur le ministre marque dont le
mexique
je m'excuse de dire c'est faux de dire
qu'il n'y avait pas un accord sur les
votants c'est une falsification de tous
ceux qui veulent ça que revient le
peuple sahraoui et confisqué ses droits
sur le nom de l'onu et de la minurso 1
c'est la mission qui est chargée
d'organiser normalement les ce
référendum d'autodétermination au sahara
occidental
quel bilan vous faites parce qu'il n'y a
toujours aucune issue
comment vous jugez sont ses actions et
son rôle en prolongement c'est là où le
bât blesse
les nations unies ont créé la mission la
mission au sahara occidental
appelée mission des nations unies pour
le référendum
cette mission at et créé pour organiser
le référendum puisque le maroc
voyez qu'il ne voulait que n'a qu'une
année pas gagné ce référendum et qu'il
n'y avait pas de possibilité de le
falsifiés sont bloqués se réfrène le
clip you nakic pied qui est le garant de
ce plan le plan légal en sont les
nations unies et l'union africaine
on se demande aujourd'hui pourquoi les
nations-unies jusqu'à maintenant qui
bloque au niveau du conseil de sécurité
cette mission de pouvoir terminer son
travail de pouvoir organiser le
référendum alors vous faisait allusion à
des européens en tout à l'heure au sein
du conseil de sécurité s'était c'est la
france c'est la transe elle apprend que
vous lui reprochez vous à la france
pendant que reprochez-vous à la france
nous reprochant à la france d'avoir de
s'aligner sur un pays de la région
contre les intérêts des autres peuples
mais contre les intérêts de la france la
france c'est la france qui a tracé les
frontières du maroc et du sahara
occidental c'est la france et l'espagne
nous ne voyons pas pourquoi la france
défend les l'intégrité territoriale
marie et pousse dans la même région
pratiquement le maroc à violer les
frontières alors que l'on sait que les
frontières africaines les frontières
héritées de l'époque coloniale sont
construites et un principe fondamental
de l'existence même de notre
organisation régionale
c'est ce et c'est grave que la france
qu'il se dit la partie des droits de
l'homme refuse à la minurso de
superviser les droits de l'homme alors
que les comparez vous dites que paris a
bloqué les décisions de la cour de
justice européenne sur des accords de
pêche des accords agricole passé entre
bruxelles à et rabat on précise quand
même que le sahara occidental c'est un
territoire riche en ressources
naturelles et du phosphate
il ya des zones de pêche et donc vous
reprocher ses intérêts qui lie les
intérêts économiques qui lie l'union
européenne et le maroc
effectivement le pillage des ressources
naturelles par des sociétés étrangères
mais surtout l'encouragement du maroc à
continuer son occupation
une explication économique c'est le
pillage de nos ressources naturelles et
la france malheureusement et l'espagne
aussi sont responsables de cette
situation et dans le même sur le malade
en même temps monsieur le ministre le
maroc a beaucoup développé ce territoire
aux signes à ses 435 millions d'euros
d'exportations essentiellement du
poisson vers l'europe donc ça veut dire
qu'il ya de l'emploi
il ya aussi des entreprises au sahara
occidental
si vous obtenez gain de cause dans le
conflit ce bras de fer
actuellement avec avec un rabat que
deviendront ces entreprises et ses
emplois
les intérêts marocains nous sommes nous
étions prêts nous sommes toujours prêts
à avoir des relations de coopération
avec tous nos voisins y compris le maroc
et même avec les entreprises étrangères
nous l'avons dit devant la cour
européenne de justice que nous sommes
disposés à signer des accords à cons
et à traiter avec les compagnies
européennes et autres sur la base du
respect dont souveraineté de notre
intégrité
nous sommes un petit pays riche nous ne
pouvons pas ne pas profiter de savoir
faire aussi bien des marocains qui sont
nos voisins et nos frères
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés parce
que ce n'est pas que le peuple marocain
je le dis c'est le malheureusement le
gouvernement dans le cadre et sur notre
peuple et c'est dommage parce que il
nous fait perdre des occasions de
coopération et de développement
mais la république sahraouie sachez bien
qu'il est que nous sommes ouverts à
toute sorte de coopération sur la base d
un mot sur la position des états unis
puisque donald trump s'est rangé du côté
américain on reconnaît en reconnaissant
la socia souveraine la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara occidental pour
l'instant joe biden il ne s'est pas
prononcé on sait qu'il ya des sénateurs
américains tout de même qui lui ont
demandé de revenir sur sa décision
bon c'est un petit peu compliqué parce
qu on imagine que les états unis soigne
le rapprochement entre israël le royaume
chérifien est ce que vous vous êtes en
contact avec un des lobbys américains
par exemple je veux dire d'avoir que le
cette déclaration de trains vire tout à
fait le droit international
c'est une grave violation de deux
systèmes de juger des des principes
fondamentaux sur lesquels repose le
système international et relations
internationales parce que le connaître
la souveraineté d'un état sur un autre
est contraire aux dispositions de la
charte des nations unies à l'avis de la
cour internationale de justice et
contraire même aux intérêts des états
unis d'amérique et à ses responsabilités
en tant que pays membre permanent
non et non des moindres du conseil de
sécurité
donc il faut dire que la dernière
déclaration du porte parole du
département d'état des états unis avait
dit que il y a une grande différence
on rentre
vision et la politique de tram ce site
question du sahara occidental avec la
vision et la politique de vieux os bada
os si vous savez ces derniers jours leur
le pentagone avait des des exercices
conjoints avec le maroc d'autres pays en
territoire marocain les marocains ont
tout fait pour que cette ces exercices
se déroule en partie dans notre pays
notre territoire occupé le pentagone a
refusé une dernière question et ses
ministres à l'attention des nations
unies au niveau des nations unies les
états unis ne peuvent pas continuer à
jouer le rhône comme le pétrole dans le
pays qui détient la plume pour les
résolutions sur la question du sahara il
ne peut pas être juge et partie
les nations les états unis doivent le
respecter la position des nations unies
je crois que l'administration de joe
biden l'a démontré durant la réunion du
conseil de sécurité
la dernière et nous espérons que cette
question de 30 soit comme lui du passé
dernière question à monsieur le ministre
votre allié soutien militaire c'est
l'algérie quelle est la nature exacte de
votre vos relations car vous revendiquez
c'est vrai l'indépendance l'autonomie
sous votre autorité du sahara occidental
mais dans le même temps est ce que vous
ne craignez pas la tutelle d'alger au
final il faut le connaître à l'algérie
sa position conforme au droit
international
conforme aux décisions des nations unies
il est du devoir de tous les états
membres des nations unies de soutenir
les mouvements de libération et les
luttes d'indépendances l'algérie l'a
fait il pas pour les sahraouis mais l'a
fait partout on en voit là en zambie en
afrique du sud en namibie pour ne citer
qu'eux que quelques-uns quelques
exemples comme le sahara occidental un
territoire africain l'algérie est un
allié talent oui mais il faut dire la
vérité ici tout ce qu'ils veulent
impliquer l'algérie comme étant le
soutien à oui je dirais deux choses la
première est que le soutien des
sahraouis c'est d'abord la légalité
internationale et 2
tout ce que les gris qui perdent
à comme armements nous l'avons fait
durant notre lutte contre les espagnols
une grande partie de la raison et
monsieur le ministre ce que vous
craignez la tutelle d'alger pour résumer
il ya aucun tutelle sur le fond pour les
accueillir
aucun titre sous l'arbitrage mais il y a
indiqué l'ama merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur mohamed salem ould
salek pour cette grande interview
accordée à rtl france
merci madame et merci à vous d'avoir
suivi cette grande interview que vous
pouvez retrouver en replay sur notre
site
rt france pointe événement réseaux
sociaux merci de votre attention et à
très bientôt
[Musique]